durch meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zur elften folge christmas
kraft wir wollten heute den
weihnachtsmarkt weiter und so wartet der
sender wieder und ich habe mir schon
grün und rot in das inventar gepackt das
waren die eier sein häuschen vom letzten
mal und ich würde sagen wir wollen
einfach genau so weit wieder auf weil
das ja eigentlich ganz cool aus also ich
denke hier kann auch so ein häuschen hin
wo menschen übrigens heute habe ich
wieder kein thema ganz einfach aus dem
grund weil wir immer auch diesen merkt
ihr bauen und ganz einfach 154 habe ich
letztens schon gesagt dass ich die
themen nicht wiederfinden kann bzw
dieses kommentar dings was ich da hat
sich etwas einmal photoshop datei und da
kann ich irgendwie nicht finden also ich
weiß nicht wo das ist oder für das
abhanden gekommen ist aber keine ahnung
da musste ich auf jeden fall noch mal
neu machen dann ach so wohin sollte ich
eigentlich diese leute einfach das passt
ja und zwar habe ich dann für diese
folge ja logischerweise kein thema
allerdings wollte ich noch ein bisschen
darüber quatschen wie das in nächster
zeit mit youtube und allgemein hier so
ablaufen wird und zwar also gewinner
übrigens habe ich jetzt mal gesagt
wurden glaube ich jetzt alle
angeschrieben habe noch keine
rückmeldung von den gewinnern bekommen
aber die wurden angeschrieben familien
minecraft das hat er mir gesagt sogar
noch an dem man selber und ja also ich
denke das ist eigentlich ganz gut
gelaufen dass tiere spieler gekriegt
haben nun beginnt natürlich wieder die
phase das ihr bis zum siebzehnten mir
wieder ganz viele kommentare schreiben
könnt und dann ich möchte hier gerne
stehen machen
ach das ist natürlich blöd aus hier noch
schnee und da auch bei schnee so schön
und zwar könnt ihr mir bis sie auf diese
partie
könnt ihr mir dauernd hier nicht bittet
eventuelle ach mist könnt ihr mir wieder
bis zum siebzehnten kommentare schreiben
mit irgendwelchen pc
weihnachtsgeschichten und dann suche ich
mir bis also halt am 16 bezüglich mit
von drei geschichten aus und lässt sie
dann am 17
und wenn ihr dabei seid dann werdet ihr
an dem tag noch von minecraft
eingeschrieben könnte eins von drei
spielen gewinnen
also ich denke ich habe das jetzt
endlich ganz gut geklärt also ihr könnt
mit witzige geschichte schreiben und
themen über die ich quatschen soll und
links jesus nochmal bau vorschläge was
ich bauen soll
und dann werdet ihr demnächst auch
wieder erwähnt wenn ich das irgendwie
wieder finden sonst sage ich da brüstet
das noch mal bei facebook
ich denke sonst ist eigentlich auch
nicht so schlimm und naja also übrigens
das habe ich schon ziemlich oft gesagt
dass wenn ihre news wollte oder so immer
bei facebook gucken und ja übrigens
außerdem news ist eigentlich ganz gut
das immer so eine folge machen welches
ein paar dinge quatschen kann dann muss
ich keine extra info video machen weil
ich halte nicht so viel von infizieren
das richtige richtig auf den seines
planes info videos macht ich hab den
abonnierten gaming videos und ich legen
info videos mit interesse die abo
also news was könnte ich dann sagen ach
ja ich mache mir zurzeit eine website
bezieht das nicht ich mache die sondern
ich mache das zusammen mit einem freund
also nicht mit einem freund seine der
hat mich angeschrien hey willst webseite
wo werde ich ganz schön dich doch mal
wieder das so gedacht hast und ich
dachte das wäre so eine normale website
des seiner gemacht damit zu schlechten
design und der katalanen davon aber der
typ der mich angeschrieben hat er hat
echt ahnung davon dass brauchen mal ganz
kurz zu
er hat echt ahnung davon und das ist
echt cool dass der das mit mir da
zusammen macht und mainland schienen
verwässert verbesserungsvorschlägen da
ausgesetzt ist ich könnte euch nun schon
die ip die website schreiben also sie
heißt control.de was bringt euch nichts
weil ich es nicht darauf zugreifen
können und jeder nur wieder zu meinem
youtube-kanal verlinkt werden
also die website wird von crafter
punkt.de heißen und dort werde ich
einerseits zwischen twitter system
machen werde und zwar wieder nicht
sondern ganz normale website sowie erste
forum und ich vor aus dem verfahren und
bei mir auch nicht sondern es wird eine
ganz coole website und eventuell werden
wir bald eine zweite website machen teil
wir haben eine richtig geile idee das
richtig witzig werden könnte
und richtig richtig bekannt werden
könnte aber darf sie dann einfach später
mehr will er wird wir gehen wir lassen
es war concept.de online kommen und
schauen wie das ankommt und danach
machen wir eventuell noch eine zweite
website aber das sagen welchen also
concept.de habe ich ja schon mal bei
facebook gepostet dann sind ungefähr
10.000 leute auf die seite gegangen ist
in den statistiken gesehen und wollen
eineinhalb mal gucken ob dieser seite
verfügbar ist
war sie allerdings nicht und deswegen
haben sich viele beschwerden von thomas
nowag aber die fans gar nicht online was
bringt ein wenig blass und dann ja
zurzeit schon aber die website zur
bearbeitung seiner website die macht man
mit ein paar stunden oder tage sag ich
mal
weil wir nicht einfach so ein template
genommen haben sondern wir das alles
selber gescriptet haben sag ich mal
und was ich machen werde david dazu wird
ein info video kommentiert
wahrscheinlich wird das am 24
kommen am 24 dezember und ja wenn alles
gut halt wenn alles gut klappt kommt das
dann
laster nicht pflaster passt ja gut ich
würde einfach sagen das war's dann
wieder für diese folge also ihr könnt
mir weiterhin dinge auch so ich wollte
die story erzählen und zwar pro a oder
verschiebt das jetzt noch ein bisschen
zeit und zwar bin ich durch weimar
gelaufen ich bei der stufe fahrt und bin
ich der stadt gelaufen und auf einmal
geht es also ich also ich halt mit
meinen kumpels waren sechs solltet ihr
so rumlaufen sind wir sehen zur andere
sechs jugendliche die waren so 14 also
waren halt so alle drei vier jahre
jünger als wir wenig das herumlaufen und
das war halt ganz witzig weil die seien
halt allerdings wie so ein bisschen halt
alle relativ normal aus und in weimar
haben wir sonst bisher nur ältere leute
gesehen als die ältere fraktions und 40
jahre oder älter sehen wir das voll
fremd land für uns dass wir damit
jugendliche gesehen und dann wir gehen
an den vorbei wir waren halt alle so um
reden sie miteinander und ich habe jetzt
ein bisschen gehört was diesen quatsch
haben weil die hat nämlich soll youtube
laden will sich nicht zeigen sich denkt
so alt aber wir reden die dann wie
werden sich nicht zeigen also meinte
dann so ein anderer von den leuten dann
nehmen vorbeigegangen sind
und dann der andere typ da wieder die
also da schon eine gruppe von sechs
jugendlichen wer eine von denen sagt er
will sich zeigen die andere sagt wie wir
ja crafter die hatte sie noch nicht
gezeigt nie hatte nicht woher soll das
mal machen und ich grinsend an den
verweilen muss richtig lachen richtig
witzig und na ja also das zu der story
von weimar und da sehe ich halt schon
was ich so für einen für einen raum sagt
ich mag dich ansprechen muss ich
vorsichtig sein was ich hier sage uns
und ich denke wenn die leute das sehen
die werden sich jetzt richtig in asch
kneifen oder als server ich werde die
chance harvey grad an dem wir uns aber
wir haben nichts gemacht und plant keine
ahnung also hätte ich glaube ich
reagiert wenn irgendwie keine angst dann
noch nicht gezeigt ich habe sicherlich
über schläge gezeigt
naja egal so hätte ich jedenfalls schon
reagiert aber egal es ist die story von
weimar und ich habe ich mir zwei minuten
über die story gequatscht
ich würde sagen schaffen wir 999 likes
für diese tollen häuschen als das ist
der dritte part von den weihnachtsmarkt
mir fällt gar nicht so viel ein was
nummer bauen könnte und dann sehen wir
uns demnächst übrigens heute ist ja der
elfte also heute ist dienstag und ich
muss schon sagen dass am 12
also morgen ist jetzt mittwoch der
zwölfte donnerstag ist der dreizehnte
und freitag ist der 14 ich kann nicht
versprechen dass dort videos kommen
also es kann sein dass dort kein
christmas kraft kommt also wenn
irgendwie leute unter videos fragen hey
warum ist heute kein christus
draufgekommen oder allgemein das
irgendwie mir schreiben und jeder sieht
antwortet ihm bitte dass das eventuell
nicht kommen wird also nicht gekommen
ist weil ich hatte keine zeit beschreibt
morgen genauso wenig hat die zufolge ihr
seht und am 14ten schreibt auch nochmal
klausur und dann danach die woche
nochmal 2 1 aber ich denke da werde ich
das irgendwie schaffen aber zwölfter und
wir sind erst mal glaube ich kein christ
kraft und dreizehnter dann
dementsprechend auch nicht also nur dass
er das west und dann würde ich sagen
schaffen wir 999 lexware sie uns beim
nächsten mal freunde rhein und tschüss